[Music]
maybe it's time Olivia always
[Applause]
it's downloaded the always takes luck to
change Hillier digs allowed to try you
know man in the old days I always knew
like you were gonna do something that
you'd be alright it's the first time I'm
worried about you can I ask you a
personal question
okay tell me something good do you write
songs or anything
I don't sing my own songs why I just
don't feel comfortable well when you
feel comfortable almost every single
person has told me they like the way I
sounded but that they didn't like the
way I look I think you're beautiful
[Music]
hey what I just want to take another
look at you
you know the good times I find myself
well change isn't going to become sing
that song hello
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how was the party
aces he's wearing a woman's sweater and
he's drunk yeah we're good parents my
name's Simon I'm just like you I have a
normal family amazing friends a lot of
my life is great
except I have one huge ass secret hey
have you seen the new post about the
closeted gay kid at school who do you
think it is
you're blue I'm just like you nobody
knows I'm gay your assignment it's nice
to know there's another guy at school
with the same secret when did you first
realize you're blue it was a bunch of
little things like my first girlfriend
back wasn't my proudest moment computer
someone leaked your emails on the school
blog I'm sorry Simon I can't do this
anymore I'm supposed to be the one that
decides win how that's supposed to be my
thing think I'm a destined to care so
much about one person it nearly kills me
me to feel you holding your breath you
are still human you're blue I might not
know your name or what you look like I
want to find you
I'm done living in a world I don't get
to be Who I am
[Music]
did you take me because you think I look
like the guy I actually broke up with
you because you don't look like a guy oh
okay thanks welcome I don't like the
Fisher on the GT scan did you test for a
chroma taupe save
strange that we keep running into each
other maybe it means something
[Music]
the only thing you really I've been to a
million audience I don't want to do it
anymore
the world keeps spinning maybe I'm not
good enough yes you are no maybe I'm not
yes you want
it's like a pipe dream this is the dream
it's conflict and it's compromised it's
very very exciting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
25 years of marriage you have nothing to
say I'll just say it I slept with
someone if you keep talking I'm gonna
get out of the car I did it just shows
how you're getting a divorce yeah
Amy heard you crying in the bathroom we
all thought it was cancer Oh God hi hi
why you drink let's get out of here let
me get out of here what are you doing
later I do there's lots of beautiful
women in this bar but I can't take my
eyes off you we gotta move
oh it's forward of you but okay should I
pull the car around have you been
drinking
I'll Drive tips of the trade your wife
cheated on you because you lost sight of
who you are as a man which take that
straw to your mouth looks like you're
sucking on it okay you're sitting there
with a Supercuts haircut and you're
wearing a 44 and you should be wearing
42 regular credit card where your
wallets what you gotta take control your
manhood pal put on some clothes please
I'm sorry this is bothering you
beautiful
[Music]
do with me I want to show you off to my
ex-wife speaker really Jeff I met a girl
and she is game changer she's your soul
mate right go get her back Wow how old
are you I'm in love with her and I don't
know what to do about it
[Music]
you and I stop being us now when I told
you that I had to work late I really
went to see the new Twilight movie by
myself but it was so bad
[ __ ] you
say garnish why we take a shirt
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
[Music]
I can show you around that'd be great
thank you so what do you do around here
read books transcribe music swim at the
river go out at night sounds fun
all right later for a quitter that
underscores
just watch this is almost a goodbye to
us and the time comes later
meanwhile we'll have to put up with him
for six long weeks muscles are firm not
a straight body in these statues they're
all curved sometimes impossibly curved
and so no sealant hence they're ageless
ambiguity as if they're daring you to
desire them oh you'll see without my
eyes
is there anything you don't know Wow by
the time I only knew how though I know
about the things that matter what things
that matter my toys you know what thanks
[Music]
shouldn't have said anything just
pretend you never did
[Music]
[Music]
call me by your name and I'll call you
[Music]
I just feel like we should assume for a
while I think we should take a break
you're breaking up with me it's not you
of course it's me it's me I don't like
you anymore
you said that I was your soul mate when
we were at that breakfast that doesn't
what count you done with the
relationship thing I'm emotionally
unavailable I'm emotionally damaged you
don't say
no emotions just sucks I guess we should
just start bedroom what's wrong with the
couch the bedroom has better light and
since we're just friends I don't have to
be insecure about my body you're
beautiful you have nothing that sounds
emotionally supportive lock that down
your ass is a little bony much better I
can work with that
okay she'd be fine I don't know what
you're doing I can't see you putting on
your black Underpants
Jamie baby yeah did your boobs get
bigger it's just sex that never worked I
don't get it bro
Jamie's different does she have a penis
where most girls have a vagina no penis
she's no different
what do you know about women okay but I
still get the offers I'm afraid it would
be a great distraction for my family
they'll love you while fast-talking and
brusque like I'm bringing home a carny
are those brains yeah he was going
through a crisscross face
we used to like though I didn't like
these guys alright come on oh wait they
take this seriously what see are we
getting too old for this sex how do I
feel so ecology I could sing some Third
Eye Blind
okay closing time
[Music]
you have a boat I live in Jersey nice
take a note fairy what's it's out to
dinner and a show you stopped by
Hollywood cliché of two vaults shut up
Katherine Heigl get stupid liar gonna
mess it up it seems you're really into
this guy do you want some motherly love
advice mom what are you doing I'm the
princess and Audrey's my bad little pony
[Music]
I believe we have a choice in this world
about how to tell sad stories on the one
hand you can sugarcoat it nothing is too
messed up that can't be fixed with a
Peter Gabriel song
I like that version as much as the next
girl does it's just not the truth this
is the truth make some friends
sorry I'm Ben I'm Augustus waters I've
been in remission for about a year and a
half maybe you'd like to share some of
your fears with the group
Cheers oblivion what's your name hey
what's your full name
hazel grace Lancaster why spin it rain
is here beautiful
[Music]
so what's your story
who's diagnosed there your real story I
am quite an extraordinary I reject that
at the hand you know Gus talks about you
all the time we're just friends I hope
you realize you're trying to keep your
distance from me in no way lessens my
affection for you yes I'm a grenade one
day I'm gonna blow up and I'm gonna
obliterate everything in my wake
I don't want you don't get to choose if
you get hurt in this world but you do
have a say in who hurts you I am in love
with you hazel grace and I know that
love is just a shout into the void and
that oblivion is inevitable and I am in
love with you all your efforts to keep
me from your going to fail
[Music]
[Music]
are you angry so angry you need to break
something
gave me a forever within the numbered
days and I can't tell you how they cry
out for a little infinity it's a good
life hazel great okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
right we've been dating for every year
now and I think it's about time people
met my beautiful girlfriend what about
us taking an adventure II like Queens
Singapore Collins wedding my family
every time I bring them up huge subject
maybe his parents up and he has to send
them money let's take a bags and get you
checked in to Krista with this so your
family is rich we're comfortable that is
exactly what a super rich person would
say they're just the biggest developers
in all of Singapore if you aren't just
rich they're crazy Rick you really
should have told me that you know like
the principal um of Asia that's
ridiculous much more of a hurry mom this
is Rachel chick she just thinks you're
some like unrefined banana there's a few
fingers no on the outside or white on
the inside it was okay I chose to raise
a family for me it was a privilege but
for you you may think it's old-fashioned
but you want it to be happy I know
you're not what Nick needs she's like
trying to play games chicken with me
thinking I'm gonna swerve like a chicken
but you Kevlar you go roll up and be
like Bock Bock bench
okay maybe even like not as aggressive
I met a girl I fell in love and I want
to marry her your Nicholas young you're
untouchable but Rachel's not if you
prepped Rachel to face the walls I
really admire you takes guts coming all
the way over here facing expanding I
know this much you will never be enough
it's about time someone stood up to Aunt
Eleanor well you not me Oh God
Chicago I was over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ever since I can remember my family has
been my whole life Rachel Rachel
Nikki tows me even those his family and
if he chose his family he might spend
the rest of his life for Zen ting you
you dad you got an ass you got nastier
[Music]
we've tried the chicken factory I'm
still having like mr. Atlas giblet with
clam petition turns out hot wax is not
my friend I'm running out of options for
you here Louisa please I'll take
anything this is New York air and
companionship for disabled man do you
have any experience of caregiving I've
never done it but I'm sure I could learn
then that's only well well this is
Louisa Clark
Nathan will talk you through wills
routines and equipment you don't have to
talk across me mother my brain isn't
paralyzed yeah he hates me every time I
speak it to me like I'm stupid
to be fair you are pretty stupid yeah
but he doesn't know that yeah
interesting choice of footwear what do
you mean by that I can't be from around
here why not
this is the kind of place people come to
and they got tired of actually living
I'm happy
well you shouldn't be gonna get one life
it's actually what UTC live it as fully
as possible
no stay tell me something good when I
was little my favorite outfit was my
bumblebee totes
bumblebee the other stripe a Bighorn you
ever loved anything that much
yes loving can hurt can I take you
somewhere on a date with will trainers
maybe get the red dress out we keep
not long ago and yet I just want to be a
man who's been to a concert the girl in
red dress a few minutes more loving can
hear a promise my parents six months is
what I've given it but happens before me
I wanted to live but only if he wants to
leave understand this happen you can't
change your people are we know what can
we do you love them I don't want you to
miss all the things that someone else
could give you
[Music]
has become a whole new person because of
you
Jenai something called you up pretty
much see anything that makes me want to
get up in the morning wait for me to
come
[Applause]
[Music]